you bought a theater in your hometown
yeah Malaga Spain is that right I didn't
find a better way to ruin myself yeah I
think my pronouncing it correctly malaga
malaga malaga think about Malibu ok
malaga malaga here you go ok thank you
all right very good we'll see now i'm
speak Spanish fluently yeah you you
bought a theater your own theater in
Malaga and that must be fantastic
because you can put up your own
productions and have any play you want
right that's a dream that I had for like
20 years because I am an actor because
of fear no because movies became an
accident an accident 112 movies I might
say but an accident but theatre was my
beginning as an actor I did a lot of
theater and so I wanted to have a
theater and it makes more sense in our
days you know it seems that what is not
recorded in our days assing exists and
theater is beautiful because no matter
how technology advances in the future
it's just about you and then there is
nothing in the mirror and that is
femoris it's just something that you see
and you just lean onto your memories I
think you're right especially in this
day of everybody having their phones
with them all the time yeah putting that
away and having that intimate experience
real and pure and beautiful is a very
special thing I love it
what kind of productions are you putting
on we open with an American production
oh what's that
core design you did Khorasan yeah at
your theater yeah did you participate in
the show I did I called I directed and I
play Zack and then the choreographer
director did you do any of the iconic
dance moves absolutely I did
I'd love to he was that I will I used to
show you yeah yeah love to see some yeah
you guys before I get to all right guys
we can go on here okay I don't think
anyone wants to see me do it okay I have
to spike its biggest punished okay no so
to the ferret this is tell Sarah that is
okay and now we go with hips and
shoulders kuvira's humerus in the oven
and okay like this life is okay no
elbows up chest up chin up on ice on the
ground look at you to see what's happen
is okay five six seven eight one [ __ ]
that one two both of them stretch like
that and now ahead ahead Punta Hedo Paso
Pattaya that okay come high kick sister
you do the kicks at the Eng yeah I just
tore my groin I heard that yeah that was
a that ripping sound was me so wait do
you have to be an amazing shape to be
able to do that I just did that Idina
for a four seconds yeah and I've had
several strokes yeah you must be in very
you must be in very good shape you know
that we are obliged by contract to do an
hour and a half
warming up they call it but it's a real
training everyday after before the
performance so when we got in the
performance we actually are getting
there already sweating yeah with the
microphones over here and it's obligated
you have to do about my contract
contractually you have to do that
so everybody is really really fit I've
been working on this for from June and
and I lost the nine kilograms and a half
yeah that's amazing
I
I'm I'm pretending I understand the
metric conversion ninety lows yeah okay
seven hundred pounds
[Laughter]